und ich bin wirklich so gespannt was
unser chef claus strunz dazu im studio
dafür bleibt bei uns und wir stellen
auch die richtigen fragen bist du zehn
toni oder bis zur team reporter ganz
klar team tony es regt mich richtig auf
dass man sozusagen nicht team tony sein
kann weil wir müssen es ja einmal die
situation vorstellen der mann ist 32 der
spielt sein ganzes leben lang fußball
der war in allen deutschen auswahlen von
u 17 über u19 bis in die
nationalmannschaft er ist weltmeister
der ist ewig oft landesmeister aber für
ihn war dieses spiel auch noch etwas
besonderes denn er kommt als einziger
deutscher fünfmal die champions league
gewann er hat seine familie eingeladen
in der stadion wie wir wissen damit er
diesen moment zelebriert sie gewinnen
das spiel mit glück und dann kommt er da
raus aufgeladen mit dieser positive
emotionen und muss sich die frage
stellen warum liverpool so gut war das
ist ja wirklich also das ja bizarr wenn
man das mal aufs privatleben überträgt
stellt euch mal vor ihr helft dem kumpel
beim umzug und ihr ladet in paderborn
lkw voll und schaffte den ganzen
vormittag und dann fährt der lkw was
weiß ich nach berlin und dann laden wir
alles wieder aus alles right time die
möbel ohne fehler ohne macken stehen am
richtigen ort alle freuen sich und dann
kommt einer und sagt ja aber im zweiten
sturm und müssen socken ausgerutscht aus
eure gäste und dann sagst du sagen oh ja
das ist wirklich ganz ganz weg also ich
für mich hat toni kroos die ich bin kein
großer fan dich war großen respekt vor
seiner leistung aber er hat mich nie so
beim herzen erreicht jetzt am wochenende
zum ersten mal hier erwarten immer ihr
müsst euch ja auch vorstellen wir
erwarten doch immer dass fußball emotion
ist wir erwarten leidenschaftliche
spieler wir erwarten leidenschaftlichen
einsatz wir erwarten jürgen klopp artige
trainer das alles lieben wir und wenn
einer dann im interview hinter mir so
etwas mal auf deine scheiss fragen hast
du wirklich bei dann sagen jetzt müsste
er aber wieder 1er schüler an der tafel
alles aufschreiben und so ist es riecht
also das ist völlig verrückt übrigens
ein richtiges deutsch aber das hat toni
kroos rechtlich das finde ich sehr
interessant ich bin jetzt auch sagen wir
mal nicht so weit gereist das sich aus
allen ländern die sitten von fußball
interviews
analysieren könnte aber es schimmert
schon so ein bisschen durch das dass wir
immer große lust am haar in der suppe
haben und das ist ja wirklich wenn du
champions-league-sieger wirst also ist
gar kein haar das ist vielleicht also
sozusagen ein millimeter von dem haar
und deswegen kann ich toni kroos total
verstehen mir ist aber auch wichtig zu
sagen natürlich kann der reporter fragen
was er will ja aber der spieler kann
dort auch antworten was er will und geht
ja manchmal auch so nah wir fragen was
und dann bekommst du nur doofe antwort
und dann denkst du dir war das jetzt
falsch habe ich aber dass es hier noch
nie aber ich glaube ja dass ich selber
auch so weiter ich glaube es fehlte ihm
in dem moment dieses in dieses gefühl
reinrutschen wenigstens für wenigstens
für die ersten anderthalb minuten und
aus dem gefühl heraus dann vielleicht
noch eine kritische frage destilliert
ich sage auch dazu warum eigentlich
warum muss man denn im moment in dem man
den erfolgreichsten deutschen fußballer
aller zeiten achtung ihrer älteren ich
finde toni kroos erfolgreicher als franz
beckenbauer als beckenbauer ist der
kaiser ab heute hat er einen wirklichen
thronfolger ab diesem wochenende
man hat also den erfolgreichsten
deutschen fußballer vorsicht der gerade
ein riesen spiel gewonnen hat selber
wahrscheinlich die düse gegangen ist
dass man es auch hätte verlieren können
wenn man nicht in zu wahnsinnigen
torwart im tor gehabt hätte liverpool
eigentlich besser war das alles führt er
aber am schluss zählt 10 basta ich bin
der größte der welt und dann muss
sozusagen
wenn auch ein bisschen diese positive
musste sich der reporter da vielleicht
einfach ein bisschen
vielleicht sogar sein ich weiß nicht in
deutschland waren wahrscheinlich die
allermeisten liverpool-fans und ja toni
kroos ist ein sehr sagen wir mal
der hat eine art fußball zu spielen die
nicht immer mitreißend ist und das ist
glaube ich auch der grund ich glaube
wenn toni kroos und deutschen reporter
sieht hat er schon die warnlampen heute
schon mit dabei seine fußball kunst in
deutschland natürlich nie
wirklich herausragend gewürdigt wurde
sondern das waren immer die anderen die
große als als leidenschaftliche spiel
entscheider und sowas in einer
allerdings so lang bei real madrid die
fäden im mittelfeld zieht und fünf mal
als spieler in verschiedenen
mannschaften champions league champions
league sieger wird dann muss man
vielleicht schon mal sagen am ende kann
das auch am ende kann das auch und
vielleicht haben sie eben auch geworden
weil sie einfach gut gespielt haben und
nicht weil liverpool schlecht gespielt
hatte wenn das sagt jetzt da kann es nur
kann man nur den großen fußball
virtuosen und philosophen jürgen klopp
zu dir die sache ist so die haben ein
tor geschossen die anderen nicht was da
so sie 10 der winter ist da und wir sind
gespannt was passiert wenn die beiden
noch einmal aufeinander treffen dann
gucken alle hin aber es wird
wahrscheinlich niemals mehr so es kann
die händler nicht